Introduction
Visual effects have come a long way since
Bruce the shark made production on Jaws a
living hell for Steven Spielberg.
Thanks to the advent of CGI, filmmakers can
do just about anything they imagine.
This has led to space ships and creatures
that look more photorealistic than ever, and
some viewers have trouble telling if what
they’re looking at is real or digital.
There’s no shortage of great examples of
these techniques, but not everyone is capable
of knocking it out of the park.
Sometimes we watch a scene and wonder what
the director was thinking when he approved
the effects.
Here are 10 shockingly bad uses of CGI in
famous movies.
X-Men Origins: Wolverine
This film is one of the most maligned in the
comic book genre for several factors, including
an apparently rushed post-production.
One of the defining aspects of Wolverine is
his claws, and fans love it when Logan brings
them out.
In this prequel though, moviegoers were angered
by what they saw.
After receiving his adamantium skeleton, Wolverine
examines his new metal claws, and they are
painful to look at.
They’re so obviously cartoonish, they look
like something out of Who Framed Roger Rabbit.
Considering that the claws looked more realistic
nine years earlier in the first X-Men, this
is inexcusable.
The Hobbit: The Battle of the Five Armies
Peter Jackson’s Lord of the Rings trilogy
was noteworthy for its extensive use of practical
effects, but the director’s Hobbit trilogy
leaned extensively on CGI.
Arguably, he went too far in a few places.
The climactic fight sequence in Battle of
the Five Armies includes a scene where Legolas
basically defies the laws of physics as he
runs up a tower that has been knocked over
by a troll.
It’s so ridiculous that even the Myth Busters
had to come out and prove it couldn’t actually
happen.
We’re all for suspending disbelief in movies,
but some things have to be grounded for us
to buy in.
The Twilight Saga: Breaking Dawn – Part
For all the advancements in CGI, it’s still
very difficult to realistically animate a
human being’s face.
The uncanny valley is something that few filmmakers
have conquered, and the people behind the
last Twilight movie failed miserably.
When Bella first meets her new baby, the infant’s
face is so blatantly digital that it sticks
out like a sore thumb.
It’s extremely disorientating, especially
when juxtaposed with the real actors on set.
One has to wonder why the director decided
a CGI face on a robot baby was the right way
to go, instead of getting an actual child
to use for the scene.
Indiana Jones and the Kingdom of the Crystal
Skull
Like so many blockbusters of its era, the
original Indiana Jones trilogy pioneered some
amazing practical visual effects, but Steven
Spielberg couldn’t resist the temptations
of CGI for the fourth installment.
Fans knew things were off from the start,
when a digital gopher popped his head up in
the first scene.
For many, this was a bad omen that Crystal
Skull would rely too much on digital technology
as opposed to the old school techniques that
made its predecessors memorable.
It was an odd choice and seemed to serve no
real purpose.
A real gopher, or even an animatronic one,
might have led to better results.
Green Lantern
As we’ve said many times before, getting
a superhero’s costume right for his or her
big screen adaptation is a priority.
Martin Campbell went in a very interesting
direction while making Green Lantern: he decided
the whole suit should be CGI.
While some comic book blockbusters will digitally
augment small sections – like a cape – this
was unprecedented and came under intense scrutiny
by fans.
The costume did not look very good on the
big screen, and even Ryan Reynolds had to
be disappointed by the results.
How else can you explain the jab at the Green
Lantern costume in Deadpool?
Hopefully for the reboot, WB makes a real
costume.
The Matrix Reloaded
The original Matrix film was one of the groundbreaking
achievements in visual effects with its bullet
time, but the sequels could not replicate
that success.
One sequence in particular that was criticized
was Neo’s fight against a swarm of Agent
Smiths.
Some felt that the effects looked fake and
cartoonish, a disappointment considering the
standard set by the first one.
A theory floating around is that the CGI is
intentionally bad because it’s meant to
represent the Matrix itself crashing but we
doubt that was the Wachowskis’ intention
when they shot the scene.
They just overdid it and audiences didn’t
respond to it.
The Mummy Returns
Dwayne Johnson is one of the most beloved
action stars today, but there was a time when
audiences laughed at the Rock on screen.
It technically wasn’t his fault, but his
appearance as the Scorpion King in the Mummy
Returns is almost comically bad.
The scene features truly horrendous CGI, to
the point where it looks like a video game.
The Scorpion King is so obviously digital,
one has to wonder if any effort was put into
his design.
Perhaps the filmmakers should have looked
for another way to bring this character to
life, since CGI was definitely not the answer.
Fantastic Four
This film had a lot of problems on its path
to the big screen, so some slight errors could
be forgiven.
That said, some of the CGI on display definitely
does not clear the bar many expect in 2015.
In one sequence, the Thing throws a tank that
immediately disappears in an explosion, without
any trace of the vehicle left.
A careful examination of certain scenes also
shows that portions of the digitally inserted
background has been copied and pasted throughout
the frame, creating a sloppy look for what
should be a visually stunning film.
Badly rendered effects were the least of this
movie’s problems, but they’re still glaring
issues.
Air Force One
For the most part, this 1990s action flick
is highly entertaining, and it features one
of the best one-liners in cinema.
Still, even its biggest fans have to admit
that there’s one scene in particular that
isn’t all that great: the plane crash.
It hardly looks like something that belongs
in a big Hollywood blockbuster, as the airplane
looks exceptionally fake.
CGI was still relatively new when Air Force
One was made, but if Jurassic Park could bring
dinosaurs back, it’s possible to realistically
animate a plane.
Or, they could have used a miniature and shot
for scale.
That usually works as well.
King Kong
Peter Jackson’s remake of this classic was
obviously a visual marvel, but there was one
section where the special effects weren’t
all that special.
When the film crew arrives on Skull Island
and explores, they’re forced to run for
their lives as they’re caught in the middle
of a dinosaur stampede.
Audiences should have been going for a white-knuckle
thrill ride, but many were taken out of the
movie by poor CGI.
In some shots, you can clearly tell that the
actors are running in front of a green screen,
with all the creatures added into the background.
Viewers knew that the dinosaurs weren’t
real, but that doesn’t excuse this.
Conclusion
Those are just some instances of bad CGI in
popular films.
Which ones did we miss?
Let us know your picks in the comments below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more fun videos!